I mean I think it's obviously the first
individual film that doesn't have to tee
up another movie it can be its own
self-contained story which is really
exciting as it means that we are not
held to anything other than ourselves
and so we can be a bit more free bit
more brave and what's great is about
everyone at Lucasfilm and Disney is that
they're encouraging that and and so I
think this film is gonna be quite
different and I think when you go to see
it you should expect the unexpected
because it's not going to be like the
saga movie it's the best job offer of my
life and so I have to do it like it's
just like the second they offered it was
late checkmate there's loads of words
that filmmakers tend to say to describe
their films and they end up being a
little bit cliched but I hope that the
one that people feel when they see ours
is that it's very realistic it has a
naturalness to everything and it's
grounded like a lot of subject views of
what it's like to be really in a war in
the Star Wars universe and the great
thing as well is because of where it's
set in the timeline a new hope the first
Star Wars movie the good guys were
really good and the bad guys were really
bad and so this is really about a time
where that black and white was a lot
more grey and good guys are doing bad
things bad guys are doing good things
and it's about a little bit more about
the nature of war and what it takes to
to do something important for the
greater good and it's never that simple
there's a heavy price to pay
you